you've had so many great parts so many
iconic roles one of the ones that I
think capture everybody's imagination so
early in your career obviously was your
Fast Times at Ridgemont High a character
you know you and I have talked a couple
of times and I've never worked up the
nerve to ask you was that character I
mean that character influenced so many
people later on in their lives or in
their acting became Jeff Spicoli and I
was curious did that character it was so
seismic for you and for everyone else
was it based on anybody well first there
was Cameron Crowe's book where he had
somebody in his mind when he wrote the
character right when I read his book
this is me at the same time as I read
his screenplay a lot of people don't
know that was a book first times at
ridgemont high first and when I read it
it was I immediately heard somebody I
knew yeah there was the guy there's a
fella that grew up in the neighborhood
where I where I grew up this is in
Malibu
yes so from I was in the valley till 69
so at 9 I moved to the beach and I was
first introduced to somebody who was
rhythmically aligned with that character
it's a very nice way to put it it was
kind of an extraordinary and so from the
time I was I guess 917 I I would see an
awful lot of him and I surfed and and so
I'd be in the water
I knew him and I just it he just jumped
off the page so this guy this is a real
person does this person to this person
ever know that he was the inspiration
for you anyway or some of the
inspiration for Jeff Spicoli I really
don't think so but part of that may have
had to do with him not knowing where he
was
[Laughter]
did you ever have you run into this
person since so about two months ago I
went out for a surf and I was coming up
this trail back to the road and this
telling his kids and family coming down
a very well-spoken guy we think a
businessman or Sean how are you and I'm
and and you know it conceded very you
know a family man and then he said his
name mmm-hmm and it was him yeah I I
would never have thought that anything
normal was going to come from